Good afternoon. Welcome everyone to
Austin ISD's boardroom for the joint
subcommittee meeting. Today's meeting is
being broadcast live on AISD TV channel
22 on Spectrum and um channel 99 on AT&T
Universe. As the board president for
Austin ISD, I will serve as today's
presiding officer. I call the meeting of
the joint subcommittee to order at 11:38
a.m. And um can we just take a moment
and go around and y'all can introduce
yourselves? Start with Commissioner
Sheay. Hi Travis County Commissioner
Precinct 2. Bridget Shay,
uh, Ryan Alter, Austin City Council,
District 5.
Belar Sanchez, Travis County Health and
Human Services, County Executive.
Um, Edna Buts, um, Austin ISD,
Intergovernmental Relations and Policy
Oversight.
Hi everyone, Vanessa Fuentes, Austin
City Counciloman. I was a proud member
of this committee last year. I'm not
technically on this committee this year.
Um, but given the topics you all will be
discussing today, I decided to to crash
the party. You're always welcome.
Glad you can join us, Council Member
Fuentes. Uh, good morning. I'm Allison
Alter, council member representing
District 10. Thank you. And I'm Jeff
Trailian, County Commissioner of
Precinct One. Thank you.
And I'm Trustee Sapata for District 2.
Great. And I'm Arthy Singh, Austin State
Board President. Again, welcome. So, we
don't have anyone signed up for public
comment today.
So, our fir I just want to make sure
right, no one's here for public comment.
Okay. So, our first item is the approval
of the minutes for February 17th um 2023
for that meeting. Do I have a motion to
approve? Approval. All right. All right.
So, we have a motion by Commissioner
Shay and a second by Trustee Sapata. Um
is all those in favor of approving,
raise your right hand.
All right, the post the uh motion uh
passes unanimously. So the next item on
the agenda is the joint subcommittee
purpose and planning. And we've set
aside about 45 to 50 minutes for the
members um that are here in this room to
disc and oh I'm sorry I forgot uh
Councilman um Jose Velasquez, are you on
Zoom?
Okay, he'll be joining us on Zoom
shortly, I believe. Yes, I'm here. Oh,
okay. There you go. Hello, welcome.
So, we wanted to talk a little bit, you
know, we we have some new members on
this board, including myself.
And um this group really brings a
variety of strengths and passions and
interests. Um we're all have this common
goal of making our community um really a
great place to live and and work. And we
each ran for office with a certain
purpose and certain goals in minds. And
now with each of our our entities get to
spend a couple of hours together every
every few weeks and really want us to
take a moment to reflect as we are in a
different time period. We're coming out
of COVID. We have um like I said three I
believe three or four new members of the
joint subcommittee. U we're in a certain
political environment. There's a lot
going on and we have a really unique
opportunity I think with this joint sub
subcommittee to do some powerful work
and if it's okay with with you all I
would love to take some time for us to
really think about what the purpose is
of the joint subcommittee we do have
bylaws of course so there is a purpose
written out but for us what would that
look like um what topics do we want to
focus on and what level of engagement do
we want to have on these different
topics. So, I want to just start off
with thinking about what the purpose is
of the joint subcommittee and I thought
it might be helpful to have some
historical um perspective for those of
you that have been on this committee for
a while and just share like what do you
see have been some of like the
highlights and and the ways that this
committee has served a good purpose. So,
I'll open the floor to anybody who would
like to speak.
Yes, Council Member Alter,
thank you. Um, appreciate the
opportunity to have this conversation.
And if I could just add by way of
background um that as the the folks
who've been on the committee um the
longest for each respective group plus
um the chair for AISD, Commissioner
Sheay, myself and um President Singh met
and and were you know did some initial
brainstorming and really were all in
agreement that this was an opportunity
that we wanted to take advantage of um
for us to to rethink and to think more,
think creatively about how we want to
use this forum, what the best use would
be for this forum. And I think um I'm
really excited today to talk about what
we've accomplished as a committee
because um as many of you may know, the
county just determined the second trunch
of their ARPA dollars yesterday and a
good piece of that had to do with child
care resources. Um, and I'll let
Commissioner Sheay and Commissioner
Travillian speak to the to the details.
Um, but part of that work that led to
identifying what we needed to fund came
out of work that this subcommittee did.
We had a working group on child care,
Commissioner Travillian, myself, um,
Trusty Boswell at the time were on that.
Um, and this was before the city had our
ARPA dollars as well was during COVID.
where we're really trying to understand
how how we could support the child care
area. The city we were able to to to
dedicate um $11 million in ARPA the
county did um first trunch and then they
just did a second trunch and AISD's also
been looking at how they can support
child care and I think that's one
example of where we've where we've
worked um together well in the past.
Thank you. Can I ask a question? Of
course. Do you mind pressing your button
though? Oh, okay. I'm sorry. Can you um
say a little bit more about where that
money went to? But what what did y'all
do? I mean, that's great. That's a big
investment. So, what did that go?
The the total money that y'all were
talking about the four. Yeah, it was 52
million and I can't recite it all from
memory, but um a substantial um amount
went to
uh workforce development and um a
particular focus and and Commissioner
Travillian can speak more to this. And
actually, if I if it's all right, if if
you don't mind, I'd like to speak a
little bit to the general purpose of
this meeting and then we can get into
more details on the how we uh voted to
allocate the federal funds yesterday.
But um from our conversation as the
people who've been on the joint
committee the longest um I think there
was a general sense that there's huge
value in having elected officials from
each of our jurisdictions gather on a
somewhat regular basis and that we
should try and maximize the impact of
that. None of us has a lot of time in
our schedules. We're all going to too
many meetings and juggling too many
things. And so for this rare opportunity
when our three overlapping institutions
which it was formed years ago because we
are the largest governmental entities in
the region whose work
overlaps whether or not we even see it.
We serve much of the same population. We
deal with many of the same crises and
issues. And um I think we can we can be
much more effective
um if we're super intentional about
trying to figure out how can we best
either pull our resources, support each
other, or pursue policies that really um
magnify the the opportunity that we have
as the largest overlapping governmental
entities. So that was kind of the
context for us wanting to have this
initial discussion where we can just
sort of brainstorm on what what could we
do that would be most impactful and I
don't mean to take anything away from
the work that we've done in the past. We
started several years back and again
there's lots of turnover but that that
newest um configuration probably
five years ago maybe longer than that
decided that affordable housing was the
major issue and that we all had pieces
to contribute uh to the puzzle and so
there was a big emphasis on affordable
housing. So, there's been really
important work that's been done in the
past. Um, but I think it's valuable to
take this time at the top of this
meeting to just I don't know if we're
calling it a brainstorming session or
what, but to try and get um ideas from
folks about what they think we should be
focusing on that can be most impactful
with the the power of these of our three
governmental entities having the chance
to sit down and work together and and
look at addressing problems in our
region. Thank you. Yeah, well said. Uh
the other some other things good things
that I've seen come out of this
committee has been um some support for
our parent support specialists. I know
there have been conversations here about
that. That is something that's a great
value to our community. Uh and also the
um community schools, right,
Commissioner Turillion? Right. Something
I've heard about. Um would you like to
share a little bit about how that
emerged from this? A number a number of
things. Um,
I think that it's it's important to
recognize
that public policy doesn't happen in a
vacuum or impact an entire community in
a vacuum. So, uh, that you have the
policy makers from the school district,
the city, and the county working
together who are generally working on
the most should be working on the most
important community related problems
across the region. Um I think it's
important and it's powerful for us to
meet together. You know, when you look
at one of the largest landholders in in
the um in the city, it's AISD. Uh when
you look at all the dollars that come a
lot of federal dollars that come in and
can address the the problems of
underserved communities, you've got the
city. uh when you have got uh a a group
like the county looking at the issues of
people who have been forced out of the
city because of affordability. So when
we when we sit together and work
together we can talk about because for
us we don't have a workforce unless
we're aligned with our school district
and we are making sure that their
workforce dollars available. Uh and and
uh I think that in many instances like
the pandemic, it was the city and the
county working together uh to make to
make sure that we were able to serve uh
those parts of town that have been
underdeveloped from the standpoint of
economic development and access to
healthcare clinics. And and I think that
our coming together served a lot more
communities that have historically been
underserved. When you look at the top
categories where we spent uh where we
dedicated our dollars yesterday,
one area was evvention um eviction
prevention, which was over $5 million.
Another area was food access,
just over $4 million. Another area,
child care assistance, about $3.5
million. Um then we've also looked at uh
workforce development because because we
know how critical that is and and I hope
that it is the work of bodies like these
who figure out how we can bring
workforce development back into the
schools. You know when I grew up uh we
had we had a shop system where a lot of
folks went to school a half day, worked
a half day, but they were taught how to
rebuild engines, they were taught HVAC,
etc. how can we build a a better bridge
to make sure that all of our kids who
are interested in work have access to do
so and then we have also focused on
infrastructure improvements including um
you know water and wastewater
development. So um a lot and and one
thing that I think the city is probably
most interested in is the jail diversion
center that we that we uh dedicated $8
million to. So there there are a lot of
things that that I think uh we all have
an interest in and and hopefully as we
work together we can figure out how we
can be even closer partners and heal and
build uh the parts of the community that
that have has have historically suffered
because they're in the wrong zip code
area. Got it. Thank you, Commissioner
Terillian. Yes, Council Member Alter.
Thank you. I I wanted to add also that
we've been um working with our staff
across the different organizations with
respect to developing our resilience
hubs um and and the areas that
Commissioner Trillian mentioned with
respect to COVID. Um things also happen
outside of this committee because of the
relationship. So I think a lot of the
food support that the city did in
conjunction with school district came
out of conversations and knowledge that
came from being in this committee even
if we didn't meet and you know arrange
to do that. Um so I think it's it's
valuable both what we do in this setting
but also the relationships that get
built and the knowledge that we have
about each other's organizations and and
and how we're working and what we're
contributing. um the prime time, the
parents sports specialists, victory
tutorial, that work that we do, the
internships, all of those things have
been really important. Um and there
opportunities
all over the place. Um workforce
development, affordable housing. Um we
also worked on the gun violence
prevention work as well.
So this is thank you um to you both of
you for sharing kind of wetting our
appetite into some of the topics that we
could be exploring in this committee. So
I thought it would be fun to to sort of
mix things up a little bit um and spend
a little time just uh I think everybody
has some postits near you.
take a moment individually to think
about what topics, whether it's, you
know, housing, child care, whatever
those big topics are. Um, and feel free
to just write them down on your postits.
I'll give you guys about three minutes
to do that. And then once you've done
that, you can put them on this big board
here. This is whenever you're ready. And
then we'll group them together and see
what uh what different topics emerge.
and council member Velasquez, we'll just
ask you to kind of pick, you know, you
can you can help help us when we get to
the discussion portion of it. So, he he
can text me his uh postits. I'll
Perfect. Thank you. Feel free to text uh
your colleague uh Council Member Alter.
And Madam Chair, I I just um we had
emailed to us this morning the revised
um spreadsheet that lays out all of the
funding allocations that we made
yesterday. Like I said, it was 52
million. So I don't have to remember
them off the top of my head. I'm happy
to share them with uh whomever can send
it out to this group. Whatever is the
most effective way to do that, I can
just forward that email so that
everybody has that list. Okay. Is that
something that um one of the staff
members might be able to assist with?
Sure. I'm just asking who I should send
it to. Edna. Perfect. Oh, yeah. Send it
to Edna. Yes. Okay. So, I'll give you
all three minutes.
Everything works well when we work with
Edney, right? And you're wanting us to
just lay out ideas that you that we'd
we'd like to work on over the next year
or so as the joint subcommittee. Okay.
Thank you. So, one topic per And then
you just put it on that board as you
finish.
How many am I limited to?
Careful.
quality.
when they're
Okay. Okay. We'll we'll get it. We'll
get it to you. Okay. All right.
Okay. Sounds good. Okay. So, um I saw so
many great ideas here. Thank you all
very much. Um so, I'll share with you a
little bit of what our categories emer
what categories emerge. So, it seems
like some of the biggies were
workforce development. Raise your hand
if you said something about workforce.
Yeah, a lot of people talk about
workforce um career and technical
education, job training and placement.
Um, we also I have this sort of
workforce adjacent
uh place here which I put this one which
is or actually no I think Trusty Sapata
did which was increase the salaries for
PSS's to $20 an hour to kind of match
what the city is doing. Yes. Um also
incentives to bring teachers to the
district and and just general staffing
challenges which I think all three of
our entities are probably experiencing
right now. So they're kind of related
there. Um, another big area of course is
housing. So, probably everybody puts
something about housing, affordable
housing for public employees. Um,
oops, this one's got to go there. And
yes, affordable housing. Then, uh, we
have a bunch with child care. So, you
can see a lot of people talked about
child care and preschool. Um, and then
related to that is after school and
summer camps as well. So our kids have a
safe and educational place to be when
they're um you know their parents are
working. Mental health is a big issue.
Diverting those with mental illness from
jail to treatment. Who said that? It's a
good one. Thank you. Thank you. Yes. Is
there anything that either of you would
like to say to kind of expand on that?
Yeah. Well, yesterday we voted 8 million
I think in change
um to do a pilot program along those
lines um with interval care using a
couple I'm sorry using a couple of
facilities that are already in place um
and that can relatively easily
accommodate
um
a population that is whose main issue is
mental health that are now going into
our jails. Y um and it would include
both um um the housing component for 30
to 90 days. There there'd be a there
would be one portion of that would be
emergency crisis and then another that
would include residential for 30 to 90
days with services to support people
transitioning out of that. Um, we we had
Dr. Strowski from uh Dell Medical lead a
a a a pretty large task force looking at
this issue and his recommendation was
that you needed to have this kind of
alternative place with the services
because if you didn't have the services
you were just creating another jail. Got
it. Um and so we're going to be piloting
that um starting fairly soon because we
allocated this federal money um to that
pilot and we'll be looking for partners
because we need to partner with lots of
entities in the community including the
city, the hospitals, um uh central
health and lots of others. Oh, that's
great. Yeah. If if I think it's really
important to uh to recognize that that
we uh that we do need the programming,
but you know, we have seen programs that
have worked at the county. There was a
DWI court that was run by Judge Bennett
and uh people would be sent to detox.
They would be given a counselor. Uh they
would be put into 12step programs and
all of those things were good. But if
you don't have housing and you don't
have job training, you don't provide the
stability that one needs. You don't want
to divert someone to the street. That's
right. You want to divert them to a bed
and divert them to services. And this
would lay a foundation for building out
that infrastructure that we've got part
of. And I think we've got a a group of
judges in uh Travis County that would
work with us, but we have to build out
the entire infrastructure in order for
it to be sustainable. Wow. Thank you for
that. Thank you for that. Um so I'm
going to mention a few of the other
things here. Oops.
So I forgot to put a little circle
around this one. This is land strategy
and park space. So that's what this
little guy is right here. Um, we had a
couple people talk about drugs and
addressing the opioid crisis,
gun violence prevention, and then we
have, of course, the other category
which included things like um more
coordination of multigenerational
support, sustainability, healthy eating
and food, food and security, emergency
preparedness and resilience. Actually,
two people talked about resilience hubs
and community schools. So, I'd like to
take a moment to invite anybody to
expand a little bit more on anything in
here that uh that they shared or if you
have other ideas that haven't been
mentioned yet.
Do you want to expandain?
Sure. We were talking a little bit about
shared use spaces, our parks, and and
just opportunities. And then I I'm
kicking myself because I can't remember
what the example was, but I had someone
in the district who came to me and said,
you know, we have a school and we're
allowed to use the park for whatever
hours, but then I I think they said on
the weekend we can't use it, and this is
when, you know, we would like to use it
the most, right? So, just making sure
that we are properly using our spaces
and vice versa. there's a city space
that uh you know AISD could benefit
from. I think our open spaces are are
good opportunities for for sharing and
and collaborating. So, thank you. And I
forgot to ask, does Council Member
Velasquez have anything as well? Or did
he text you? I got it. Oh, you got them.
They're already covered here. Okay,
good. Can they hear you? I think so. Can
they hear me? I don't think he can hear
you. He can hear everybody else. Okay.
I'm going to turn on your mic if you
don't mind.
Okay, I'll just talk louder. Um Archie.
Yes. Um when I was on the city council
in the early 90s, we did a joint use um
initiative um that came out of John
Sharp's um uh performance review and
recommendations for how communities
could uh collaborate on facilities that
would be jointly used by the community.
Um and I thought it was a brilliant
recommendation.
um we passed it. Um I had understood at
that time that it was the school
district's policy to um when building
new schools create park space that would
be available for the whole community.
So, I think it would be uh good to
understand has that policy changed um
and and just what the status is like if
if a park is closed on the weekend at a
school that that doesn't make any sense.
So, it'd be just good to know what that
policy is. Well, you know, Sharp's a
couple of Sharp's policy recommendations
were put in place with Pickle and then
with Overton and and what the policy was
at the time, if I recall, what the
policy was at the time, if I recall, was
anytime the school wanted to build a new
school building, uh that it would
collaborate with the city to determine
whether that was a good place to uh to
put a rec center. And when you look at
Pickle and Virginia Brown, uh when when
you look at Overton and the Turner
space, uh it was designed to if if uh if
the city puts a larger recreation space
there, then that's less of an investment
that the school district has to make.
And if the school district puts a a uh a
commercial kitchen there, uh that is
less of an investment that the uh the um
city would have to make in that type of
facility. and and the and I think that
it has worked spectacularly well uh to
the point where we have been asking
school districts in the county to give
the same consideration whether uh there
is a space in a new school where we can
put um and and extend the uh the
opportunity to to build a community
center or a rec center or whatever you
whatever you call it. But that I think
has a real opportunity to make our
schools community centers and centers of
activity uh for the entire neighborhood.
Love that. Love that. Thank you for
sharing that. U actually can I have
trusty safa?
So I I uh I put my first one as
workforce workforce because um I think
there's been investment for years on
some partnerships that we mentioned
earlier like prime time and parent
support specialist and and and summer
youth employment is some another another
investment that we do all three of us
have been doing it for years over 20
years. Uh but it it's kind of been like
its own little thing. It happens in the
summer and then and then the staff start
all over.
Well, you know, when I started here, I
was like, how do we integrate more? How
do we use that program more to help our
students that the some employment would
be the stepping stone at ninth grade to
begin to explore a job and what that
world of work looks like. So, by the
time they go, they're in the 12th grade,
they already have an idea of what work
is, what kind of jobs, uh, skills they
know or don't know, and what kind of
what their dream job is going to be
after high school. So, then they're more
informed and prepared because they have
taken ownership of their school since
that first job experience. so that
they're um they know if they're going to
go to a four-year college or they're
going to go to Capital Idea. Uh Capital
Idea is huge because it is free and our
students who cannot or do not want to go
to four-year college can go to two-year
college for free and get all expenses
paid and their scholarship money. They
can live off of that. So that after that
what I've heard from some alumni from
Capital Idea that once they did that
then they said oh I want to go ahead and
go to my get my my bachelor's. So you
know so that I think it's we're at the
point I think where we need to go deeper
and how we integrate what we're already
investing in uh so that we can see the
fruits of all that all that work that's
been there but it's kind of been on a on
a standalone. the same thing with prime
time and and the P PSS work. So, I just
wanted to share that that that's
something that this year and uh and I'm
glad Miss Howard is here because um uh
we uh AISD is now hiring 50 over 50
students this summer through some of his
employment and and so you know and it's
helping again and the beauty of it is um
the Miss Fannon who is over who's going
to be overseeing is doing individual
meetings with every student so that they
know where they are academically and how
this work, you know, just checking in to
see how their job experience is really
going to help energize them to develop
that that thrive for the next school
year, right? So, I just want to tell you
that's that's really exciting for me to
see that happening and and we can
continue to grow that and begin thinking
deep in everything that we already
partnered in to see how we can uh uh
again expand and uh and make bigger
things happen. Thank you. Thank you.
Council member Alter
very uh where I was largely where I was
going to go, but that just that some of
these things that normally we wouldn't
think of as connected, you know,
thinking workforce and your after school
or summer camps, right? if it especially
at the older ages where you could have
um either afterchool
programs that are some form of
development or just exposure to various
areas. Um, you know, the the easy one
is, you know, the our need for
lifeguards, right? If they go from
school to go be lifeguards, that's great
for city of Austin. But you know if
there are either summer opportunities or
after school opportunities to go even be
exposed to whatever the various
departments you know I think of the
things the the engineering all the
engineering um things we have positions
from our our water utility to our
electric utility to some of the other
things that that we can tie uh
opportunities
and and kind of two birds with one stone
situation. Love that. Did you have
something to add?
Um, I wanted to talk about the
sustainability questions because I think
there's some real opportunities for us
to make sure there's knowledge across
the organizations of the different
sustainability efforts um that we're
doing. Um, and then
information I think we may need as a
city to know how we can be more
supportive and know what the hurdles
are. I know that had a lot of
conversations with Commissioner Sheay
about purple pipe um for reclaimed
water. Um, but you know the the work
that we're doing with respect to solar
energy rebates um but just generally
there programs that you guys may be
doing that we may not be aware of that
we might want to adopt. um that I think
we could we could be exploring more um
the work that you guys are trying to do
with the electric buses. We need to make
sure that you know Austin Energy is
prepared to support that. Um I think
there's some some opportunities there um
that we could really consider. Um
because we are such large land holders
in the community, we have our own
facilities. We can demonstrate how
things work. there may be, you know,
other purple pipe or water reclamation
projects that could be done, you know,
within a school setting on the
properties as you're as you're going.
Um, I think there there just some some
opportunities for collaboration that I'd
like to see us discuss and and consider.
Love that. Um, yes. Yeah, just building
on that. um because you mentioned a
number of thing that's things that are
really where we have overlapping either
programs or interests and I don't know
that we have a good mechanism for even
knowing what those are
and um my colleague Jeff Trail is
frequently talking about asset maps but
it it might be useful exercise to just
um somehow try and capture what those
are because we've got um we've directed
our transportation staff to um pursue a
transition to electric vehicles for all
of our fleet vehicles and even our law
enforcement uh vehicles as the battery
life and cost uh issues, you know,
balance out. Um so and that's going to
mean we'll have a greater need for
charging infrastructure and there's
there's a lot of opportunities with the
federal um legislation that that the
Democrats passed. I'll just say um and
providing a tremendous amount of funding
for those kinds of things. But um it it
is it's really valuable for us to
understand what's what's going on in
each of our respective jurisdictions.
But one of the things that strikes me
that is an over kind of umbrella impact
to all of us is the impacts of climate
change. When um Mara hit, it affected
everybody. And I thought AISD did a
great did a great job, updating parents,
keeping people informed about what was
going on with the schools so that people
knew if they had to come get their kids
early or would not be able to bring
their kids to school the, you know, the
next day or the following days. So, um,
it affects all of us and it and it and
it presents as a an emergency on our
doorstep every time it happens and I
just think that and I I really
appreciate the work that's been done on
the resilience hubs. Um, and I think we
should spend more time. We have that as
a written thing that we can look at and
ask questions if we if we have it. But,
um, I think there's more that we can do
on the preparedness side. Um, when I
took office, I started looking at
programs out there that we might be able
to piggyback on. And the closest thing I
could find was what they do in Japan to
prepare communities for the impact of
earthquakes and tsunamis, which are
frequent and deadly there, but very few
Japanese die from them because they all
know what to do. And the instruction for
any of our State Department people is
follow what the Japanese do. They didn't
even bother trying to give them
separate, you know, training or
instruction. So, and part of it is
because they they start in school and
school children on up all know what to
do. So, I think that's the kind of thing
that we are going to have to start
looking at because we will have more and
more disastrous weather impacts with
greater frequency. we won't be able to
predict what each one of them is, but if
there's a a commitment to uh some level
of preparedness that um that the
community is uh taught or is made aware
of so that people can be better prepared
when there will be the inevitable
impacts from extreme weather. Uh and I
just think there's there's there's so
many applications there, but it's
something we all have to deal with. It
doesn't distinguish between a city or a
county or a school district and it's an
emergency when it happens. So, we have
to drop everything else we're doing to
deal with that. I appreciate that. Yeah,
the standardized protocols can be
life-saving. Yeah, exactly. For sure.
Well, thank you. So, I'm going to shift
a little bit. Um, so thank you guys for
doing this and what we can do is capture
this in a document and maybe at the next
meeting or between now and the next
meeting we'll continue to refine this
and think about where we want to be
spending our time as a group. Uh, in
addition to the topics, what I heard
from hearing you all is like there's
sort of different levels of ownership
that the JS um that this JSC would have
on whatever it is whatever work it is we
do. I feel like just in the few meetings
that I've participated in, they've been
really helpful um in different ways. So,
one level that I see us sort of
interacting or helping each other on is
just basically like informing each other
like, hey, this is what's going on, you
know, um in in the city or here's
something that's happening, you know, in
the district. I wanted to put this on
your radar just as a courtesy um and
that type of thing. But then there might
be categories of um support we can offer
each other or just uh asking for help on
a very specific initiative. So for
example, you're going to be hearing some
stuff later today about um what's
happening in the district and there
might be a specific ask for help with
supporting one of our middle schools um
and that type of thing. So I kind of
feel like that could be a really useful
way for all of us to just sort of be
working together. And then there's this
other category where we might create
like our own like if there's some one or
two things from this list that really
emerge as super important whether it's
you know environmental um sustainability
or or some other thing that it's kind of
like our own sort of project where we're
all sort of putting our puzzle pieces
together sort of like we do with the
resilience hubs or you know um things
like that. So, I kind of think of that
as as do art. Yes. I think it's a great
idea. Maybe what we can do is get all of
the categories that are listed and send
them to everybody to identify
uh investments that we have made in
those areas to determine where we are
aligned and to see if that we see if we
can do something together. Love that.
Love that. And so that's kind of like
the whole the asset Um, I'll just use
the term that I heard. It's kind of like
the asset mapping, the investments,
where can we kind of, and I think that
would apply probably to several of
these, mostly with this category, that
category, but does that sound like a
good road map for us going forward? Is
there anything that you guys any
suggestions, ideas?
I think it would really help just uh
focus us and give us a better sense of
where there are opportunities where that
we may not be aware of now. Okay. Good.
Good. So, um yes,
I think it's a it's a great framework
for us to be thinking through and and I
do want to add that I'm not sure that
all of the do work happens within the
framework of the committee. Um I thought
it was very useful when we had the
subcommittee of the subcommittee. That's
right. For for child care and and I'll
be happy to to to work on that one
again. Um but I think that a lot of the
work happens not in this meeting if
we're actually going to be moving the
needle. I think one of the challenges
we've had in the past is that we've come
to rely on staff to come forward with
trying to figure out what what it is we
want to know without giving them very
much guidance. And so I think as we're
working and we're making this committee
uh function at its optimum so that we
can get the most out of our time here,
we are also going to have to think about
having those committees or you know
having you know the three of us meeting
periodically to say okay this is what
should be on the agenda working with
staff so that it's not as much guesswork
on their part as to what we want or
taking one comment that was one sentence
and trying to figure about what a
presentation looks like. That also makes
a lot of work for the staff. Um, and it
doesn't give them clear direction as to
what it is that we want. And I think we
can be mindful we we have great staff
who are coming to these meetings and
hopefully these meetings are also an
opportunity for them to connect um over
issues. Um,
but we should be using those resources
to the maximum.
Yes, I I fully agree and and I think um
maybe we take it a step further uh by
putting a form together that allows us
to describe the background and describe
the objective so that we can really
explain what it is we're after. So that
hopefully uh the result of that type of
request would be a a basic project plan.
just say if we were going to do this we
would have to do A B C D um you know
this is not something that we own the
data for the data is owned here uh it's
gathered every 90 days so that we have
clarity about what the idea is and what
we want what the objectives are and what
we want the outcomes to be but but then
we give them the information that's
necessary to put a plan together that we
would look at and say that's kind of
what I'm looking for or not so much I
love that. Yes. Thank you. So, we'll
capture this. We'll try to put something
together for you all to respond to and
continue working on as we refine this.
And uh Trusty Safata, one last comment.
So, as you draft this uh and put it in
category, maybe we could all be thinking
about which committee, you know, to be
on and and and and note it on there. So,
then we can begin having those me
subcommittees. I agree. that's where the
real work needs to happen. U and I think
those committees could create their
goals. I I don't I don't know we have to
have a scripted goal criteria but that
every committee is going to be
different. So uh each committee could
really work on what those goals are and
how they want to reach it and what and
bring it back to everybody else to to
see what you know where people are. But
I think I'd like to move on stuff. I
don't like to let's read and let's wait
and three months and three months, you
know, I want to see I want to see
movement. I want to see action and so um
I I just like to add that part that
people sign up to the committee that
they're most interested in. Thank you.
Yeah. So, we'll um I'm looking at
Council Member Alter and Commissioner
Sheay, so we have a little bit of work
to do figuring out a good next step, but
we'll um we'll keep everyone informed on
that. So, thank you all for this. Um,
always fun to do things with postits,
right, Trusty Lugo? She taught me this
approach. We use it like in 90% of our
meetings, I think. Um, but it's been
very helpful. So, next we are going to
talk about a topic that I think is
really near and dear to every single one
of us. And um
and I'm just so excited because Kathy
McCor is somebody who I've come to rely
on as an expert and I will often text
her during meetings and be like, "Hey,
tell me can you tell me this or give me
this statistic." So today we have Kathy
McCor here to give us um really the the
the scoop on child care needs in Austin.
Um,
there's also a workforce lens to this
that's really important. And so Kathy
McCor is the vice president of Success
by Six, which is part of the United Way
for Greater Austin. And I believe she
might be getting her presentation up.
So, um, we're very excited to have uh to
have her here today with us.
By the way, I believe you all got an
email that had a little video. Did that
that did go out right? Okay. So, I don't
know if you all had a chance to watch
that, but I thought it was very well
done and um look forward to hearing
more. So, thanks. Welcome, Kathy. Thank
you. It's an it's an honor to be here
today and um and again, a thanks to
county commissioners for your vote
yesterday. It's onetime funds. We have
it. I got it. Um thank you for that. Um
and thanks for the opportunity to share
today. I wanted to start with a little
bit of level setting about the early
care and education ecosystem
and if you could go to the next slide.
Um just for context um we do have a
robust communitywide coalition the
success by six coalition that has been
convening since 2012 to advance goals
around early care and education and the
full ecosystem of the early early
childhood sector in our community. And
you can see the organizations listed on
the far side. Um th those organizations
have representation on the leadership
team of the coalition and help shepherd
and and govern the strategic plan moving
forward. And we work to align resources
within our community across the city,
county, and school districts to advance
the goals of the strategic plan. Um the
first plan was launched in 2012. Um,
prior to the pandemic, some of the
results that we've seen in our community
were increasing school readiness by 10
percentage points over five years. We
helped launch the um, preK3 program in
Austin ISD with public private
partnerships um, with philanthropy
setting up the classrooms and then
leveraging state funds to open them and
that expanded into a full pre-K3
program. We've tripled the or city and
county have tripled their investment per
low-income child since 2012 and we have
one of the highest percentages of
highquality early care and education
programs in the state.
Next slide. However, just some stark
statistics for you to keep in mind. 28%
of the children under age six in Travis
County live in households experiencing
low income. That's about 200% of the
federal poverty level. That's 25,000
children under age six and 90% of those
are children from children of color.
So we have a far way to go. The next
slide
snowsa shows a snapshot of the framework
of our strategic plan thinking about
what do children need in their first
five years to enter school happy,
healthy and ready to succeed. They need
healthy beginnings, adequate health and
mental health care for themselves and
their caregivers, supportive families,
parents that have experience, education,
opportunities, resources to be their
child's first and best caregiver. High
quality care and education settings when
parents are at work. And then a safe and
stimulating community, things like parks
and libraries that are equipped to meet
the needs specifically of families with
young children.
In our context, babies are born
learning. Children do not begin learning
when they enter school. They are born
learning. And whatever environment
they're in, that is an early childhood
learning environment. And we want all of
those places and spaces where children
are cared for to have the resources and
supports and connections needed to
provide high quality experiences that
nurture that child's development.
And you can see on this slide um we work
with organizations in the coalition and
bring together groups like any baby can
of communities and schools aspire
program more of a twogen flavor of
programs that do home visiting or group
setting work where where moms and dads
and and children are together and being
supported. And then in high quality care
and education, we think about the
different settings like prek, head
start, and child care. And all of those
um receive some element of funded funded
dollars, very different kinds of
resources and have different eligibility
requirements. And it's important to
understand the interplay of these
because if we build out one sector of
this ecosystem without adequately
supporting another, it has unintended
consequences.
So, next slide,
a snapshot of prek in our region. Um,
80% of eligible children are enrolling
in prek four. So, we have full day prek
for four-year-olds and we know as far as
the children who are potentially
eligible to be enrolled, we're doing a
pretty good job. Those kiddos are in the
pro in the classrooms.
Does prek four mean uh starting at age
four? Okay. Yeah, four by September 1st
of the year the school year and there is
state funding for any student who turns
four um by September 1st they are
allocated state funding and have to be
enrolled in a prek program and there
with house bill three the early ed
aotment was intended to help support the
cost for full day prek we know there are
lots of asks on that early ed aotment
but when we look at prek three or prek
for threeyear-olds by September 1st we
have only 22% of eligible children
enrolled. And we think for most for most
case a lot of that is because it's not a
full day program. It's a half-day
program. If you're a working parent,
drop off at what 8:00, pick up at 11:30,
that doesn't work. And then you still
have to peacemail meal child care for
the rest of the day. However,
thankfully, AISD does have a mechanism
through preK partnerships and
partnerships with Head Start and Child
Care Centers that we can blend funding
to create a full day program. And in
PreK Partnerships and just want to
acknowledge John Greeno and my director
Madison Mati who who lead this work, we
have 18 child care centers across the
community that provide that full day
wraparound drop off pickup. We blend in
bra childcare subsidy money and prek
money and parents have that opportunity
to be dropped off in the morning, picked
up, but they have the prek curriculum
from AISD and AISD prek experience. Are
those in conjunction with um AISD or
other school districts or are they
separate? It is in conjunction with
AISD. The students are technically AISD
students. They count towards AIDS
enrollment. So there's 18 school
facilities that have a full day for 16
centers in Austin and we're partnering
in Round Rock ISD as well and two
schools. Kathy, if I could just add
here. So the preK3 enrollment um is one
of the areas that I think would be ripe
for a childare subcommittee to be
looking at to see how we could mobilize
the three entities to help increase
that. Now we have to be careful when we
do that um because it has implications
for the rest of the child care system.
So it's not an thing you can do sort of
in isolation but it is an area where I
think working together and even just
raising the opportunity and more with
more voices um could be helpful.
Thanks so much. If if I if I could an
area of particular focus for for for me
here is a title one environment and as
close to free as possible. Uh because um
many communities affordability is not an
issue. uh but when we look at where our
low performance is happening um it is it
is almost geographic
and so it's important to focus on
building the type of system that the
Austin project built that AV is working
on now how do you focus on the resources
in an area and identify map them uh so
that people can get the the all of the
things that they need to be successful
but that that um we work in those
environments where ultimately you get a
a huge bang for the buck. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Well, I'll keep going
because I know we we don't have a lot of
time, but next slide. Um again, this
snapshot in our Head Start is federally
funded. It's allocated to both AIC gets
a portion of Head Start seats about 200
and uh Child Inc. has the majority of
the seats allocated. They have about
1,200 seats combined between early head
start to three and head start three to
four year olds. They are underenrolled
this year because they can't hire
sufficient staff to use up all their
seats um to fill all their seats. So
there there's funding being left on the
table unfortunately for that. Um and
then we have child care scholarships or
subsidies. We're trying to change and
and call them scholarships
um because it's more of a strength-based
approach.
Travis County through uh Workforce
Solutions, the city of Austin and Travis
County um the childcare subsidy program
is managed by Workforce Solutions.
They're allocated a target of 3,57
children per day with the funding they
receive from the state. That's birth to
13. And remember, we have 25,000 young
children under age six living in
low-income households.
When we look at the distribution of
child care subsidies, just the result of
how referrals are made and placed, um,
fewer than 1,000 infants and toddlers
are enrolled on an average day in in our
subsidized child care program. Right
now, we have 1,345
children on the subsidy waiting list.
930 of those are children under age
three. So when we look at the biggest
gap of need, it is in the infant toddler
space.
It's also important if you did watch the
video, thank you. PreK expansion without
stabilizing the infant, toddler child
care sector unintentionally destabilizes
the the whole system because child care
programs pay for the costs of their
infants and toddlers by co covering
those costs with the tuition or subsidy
they pull in for the prek students
because they can have more children in
those classrooms.
Does that make sense? Yeah. Can you just
say why if they're funding over 3,000 um
slots per day that they have fewer than
a thousand using it? Just fewer than a
thousand infants and toddlers. And part
of that is we have we have limited seats
for infants. Um programs can't afford to
offer child care for infants
um at the subsidy reimbursement rate.
And so they won't they they'll accept
preschoolers or afterchool child care,
but they won't accept infants because
it's not it doesn't work with their
business model. We also are finding a
lot of programs are closing their infant
classrooms um because they can't staff
and those are the expensive classrooms
to open. So I don't want to take up too
much. Seats are filled. They're filled.
Yeah. Okay. That's what I didn't
understand. But only a thousand of them
are they're There are only a thousand
are utilize utilizing or supporting
infants and toddlers. The rest are
supporting children older 3 through 13.
Okay. It'd be good to have a breakdown
of the 25,000 because that's six and
under. Yeah. So I I don't have a sense
of the size of those populations. I can
get that for you. Thanks. Um and just
for clarity, prek eligibility is is 185%
of the federal poverty level. Head Start
is 100% of the federal poverty level and
child care subsidies is 85% of state
median income. So if you're a parent of
a three-year-old,
may the odds be ever in your favor in
navigating that system. Um unfortunately
it's just how how we operate in Texas.
Um next slide.
Again just pointing we have a massive
problem with child care in our state and
and I do think of that as highquality
early care and education. It can be high
quality if sufficiently re resourced.
This state is um not investing and and
we have really poor standards for child
care generally but in our community
we've worked together to elevate those.
If you go to the next slide um the child
care system has been deemed a market
failure.
High quality infant care can cost over
$20,000 a year. Um, it costs more than
tuition at UT for almost all child care
in our region. And most families cannot
pay the true cost of care. What happens
is we compress the teachers wages and we
we provide care on the back of the
workforce and the child care sector. We
have really high turnover um in this in
this sector and we estimate that the
loss of those programs who are for every
child they enroll that is supported by a
child care subsidy if they're
maintaining high quality standards,
they're losing between 3,000 to $5,000
per child per year based on the
insufficient reimbursement rates.
Next slide. Just a little more about the
market failure. They operate on a 1%
profit margin. Most child care programs,
um, we've been seeing a consistent
reduction in just the number of seats
across the region. That means programs
that are willing to accept children
supported by subsidies. And then when we
lock look at like where where's the room
to move things around within the child
care business model 60 to 80% of their
costs go to wages. Um and then another
20 to 40% goes to occupancy. So they're
paying rent or they're paying mortgage,
they pay property taxes, utilities, etc.
This is an opportunity for um
colllocations using existing assets,
public facilities, etc.
Um and it's a particularly hard problem
in Austin right now as you can imagine.
The next slide just shows a little bit
about what's happening with the
workforce. We know there's a terrible
crisis of a teacher workforce. I would
say the child care staffing crisis is
not teacher workforce crisis on
steroids. Um, if you go to the next
slide,
um, only one out of 10 early childhood
educators earns a living wage. Average
wages in Austin are 12 to$13 an hour.
And, and nearly every child care program
is having trouble finding sufficient
staff. That means they shrink hours.
They close infant toddler classrooms.
Um, they don't operate the hours that
working families truly need.
And next slide. We know that we're
ignoring long-term outcomes from this.
There have been several reports recently
about the economic impact of lack of
affordable child care on our workforce.
But y'all, we're talking about employer
productivity, sales tax revenue,
workforce participation. All of these
could increase if we had sufficient
access to highquality care. And it must
be resourced to provide highquality
care. You can't expect quality without
paying for it.
The next slide is similar just a little
bit about workforce participation. So I
don't want to um spend too much longer
on that. And then the last two slides if
we can flip through relatively quickly
or just documented um pieces of
information we have about the strong
return on investment if we do invest
early. We have the least amount of
public funding in the first five years
which has the most significant period of
brain development. And if we don't pay
upfront, this last slide indicates how
we pay more later. We have to invest
more in retention, in interventions, and
special education um and later on things
like involvement with the justice
system, etc. instead of workforce
participation.
That was your childare 101
speed round. Yes.
Um, so I know that the ARPA funds back
in 2021 were made available to all
states. Um, and I don't know, sometime
earlier this calendar year, actually,
no, last year, um, I had reached out to
some folks at TWWC to try to find out
how did Texas invest those dollars?
Yeah.
Yeah. the punch line. Um, Commissioner
Shay got to it, but how what has, you
know, what can y'all do here in our
central Texas region? So, there's the
difference between the state and the
central the state has done a lot of
stabiliz stabil stabilization. They
shared out stabilization grants. They've
had short-term increases in the subsidy
reimbursement rates. Those are all
coming to an end. Um, and and we weren't
in a great place for child care before
the pandemic. So, anything that was
invested through the pre pandemic
recovery funds is really just trying to
get us back to where we were, which
isn't where we need to be. Um, local
investments have been incredibly helpful
in building out things like the pre-K
partnerships that can leverage the state
education revenue into the child care
sector, trying to strengthen the
business model of our childare programs,
and trying to begin really working more
intentionally, explicitly with the
family-based providers who are often
left out and disconnected from local
resources and supports. All right. And
then I know there's also CERSA funds.
Um, I forget how to spell the acronym,
but it's like CR RSA, I think. Um, and
those are rather than being
stabilization funds. Uh, some states are
using some states, I don't know about
Texas, but some states are using them um
to encourage longer term uh workforce
investments like specifically in child
care and early child care. So um not
again not sure
to what extent you know our region can
access those dollars. I completely
understand you know difference between
the state and local but you know
sometimes magic can happen. Yeah. Yeah.
I I'm not familiar with the CERSA funds
at this point but I'm happy to look into
it. I don't Lawrence I don't know if
you're familiar with those. Yeah. Yeah.
So yeah, I would say just really briefly
um yeah, there's like student loan
forgiveness um for child care workers um
and also um incentives for just being a
childare worker, especially in child
care deserts. So again, I you know,
right, there's certain things that would
be applicable, certain things that
wouldn't be. Um, the other thing I
wanted to just briefly mention, so not
really a question but more of a comment
is, you know, when I think about child
care, so I got three kids, right? 12, 9,
five. Um, and I was so happy when my uh
youngest
entered preK4, it was like getting a
raise. I Yeah, really. Um, so all of
that to say, you know, the other thing
that comes to mind is not just the
affordability and the partnerships and
kind of looking at, you know, when you
move one domino, what else falls, but um
really looking at some opportunities,
you know, the collocation a and on top
of that looking at, you know,
multigenerational
um impacts. So I think you know the
aellas, the theas, the you know uh
individuals who might have retired from
work but want to um have another career,
right? I'm like how amazing and powerful
is that when um you've got
crossgenerational interaction both all
all folks um benefit from that. And then
along those same lines, the partnerships
that um currently exist to help parents
and current caregivers um and connecting
them to or receiving them from workforce
development. I mean, I think that's
huge. Um and the last thing I'll say is
yeah, the the sooner we can get kiddos
into AISD and really have them become
part of the AISD family, the the better.
And I think that's the other thing I
would love to see is really having our
city um not that this hasn't already
taken place, but maybe just um more
overt um a more overt embracing of AISD
as part and parcel of the city, right?
Like what is the identity of our city?
You know, quality child care through
AISD, right? Like there's lots of ways
that we can do that and and really
promote that. So yeah, thank you Trusty
Luga. I think we have time for about one
more comment. Commissioner, I know
there's been some talk about a a ballot
initiative. I don't know at what point
it makes sense for us to be briefed on
that, but um it's clear we have to find
additional sources of of funding. And um
I don't know if you all have done this
analysis because you've done such
phenomenal analysis on so many aspects
of this, but I'd be interested to know
how other countries fund it. I mean, we
hear so much about how European
countries have excellent child care
programs that the state funds um you
know, or somehow they're funded. It'd be
really interesting to just understand
how they do that and what the costs are
because I we clearly don't have good
working models and it would be good to
know what some of those are. Thank you.
Yeah, I'm happy to I have I have some of
the information on the the international
models and also would note that they
have often more robust paid family leave
that reduces the the stress for infant
care and the cost of infant care. So
that can also be a a lever, but I'm
happy to bring that information back. I
I will say um currently underway is a
project with the children's funding
project doing cost modeling and fiscal
mapping so that if we are asked what
would it take in Austin so that we had
funds for every
uh child up through age four for
highquality early care and education.
What would that cost be and how do
what's the gap from what we currently
have? I can promise you it's a huge
number. It is hundred million dollars
annually. It is it's a big number, but
that's the work that um we have some
staff and programs working on right now
to try and just have that answer for our
community. And then that asset mapping
would be really important because I've
heard directly from Workforce Solutions,
they spend 54 million a year currently
on childare. And I was floored when I
heard that because I didn't have a sense
that we were getting anywhere close to
addressing our childare needs. that I'm
just astonished that they're spending
that amount of money on child care.
Yeah. Thank you. And just when we say an
asset when we say an asset map, what
we've been trying to do is identify all
of the programming wherever it is and
whether the dollars are federal uh state
or local just to have an idea of what's
being well what we're serving but then
also where the gaps are so that we can
put place our focus there. Um we did
that with the food policy with the food
policy council the food network and it
was a very instructive document uh that
that uh led us to make more investment
in food access. Well I also uh didn't
hear maybe I missed it um about our teen
moms uh you know how are they getting
support um and you know if y'all have
any information on that later I' I'd
appreciate it.
Thank you. They they are a priority
group for workforce. That's great.
Subsidies. So, thank you so much, Mor.
This was wonderful. There's clearly a
lot of interest. I want to take a quick
second to make sure all the all your
colleagues were introduced. Would you
all mind introducing yourselves and then
if there are other um folks working from
ASD or the city involved in childcare,
could you just stand up and introduce
yourself quickly?
directorship.
Thank you.
Wonderful.
the executive director of school
programs with Austin.
I'm Jeremy. I'm the third base director
for Austin
school program.
Fantastic.
I'm Jeremy. I'm director
Austin.
And you're finding the space for
collocation. Is that what I heard? Yes.
Enthusiasm. Yo,
that's exciting. I think that's
exciting.
That's right.
Thank you. But if you're looking for
other uh space, um the the county is has
a partnership with numerous multif
family developers that are developing
somewhat largescale sites that are
taxexempt. So the any of the common
space they have um is not taxed.
Further introductions.
Wonderful.
Susie
superintendent. I work with students
which early learning is one of those.
Thank you.
Oh, wonderful.
All right. Did we get everybody?
All right. Well, this is a good um Thank
you again. We really appreciate this.
You can see this is something that we
all I think are very passionate about
and um you've given us a good start in
this or continuation in this direction.
So next we have we're going to move on
to some talk about AISD
and we have with us our interim uh
superintendent Matias Seura
and he's going to talk to us about uh
the Texas Education Agency and some um
updates around special education and
Mendes Middle School.
Hello. Uh, thank you. I didn't realize I
had a a place to sit here. I appreciate
that. Um, well, good evening or good
afternoon, uh, trustees, commissioners,
city council members. Very much
appreciate the opportunity to provide an
update regarding special education
services, uh, our current engagement
with TEA as well as an update regarding
Mendes Middle School. And so, uh, as we
move to the next slide, the first thing
I'd like to communicate to you all is
that when I first came on board, it was
clear to me that special education
services and improving the services uh,
for our students was priority 1A. Uh,
it's something that the system as a
whole needed to acknowledge um, you
know, and and really embrace the
challenge that we had in front of us.
And so I'll tell you since the the first
day that I started in this role that has
consumed a significant amount of my
time. Uh but we've over the period of
three months really done incredible
amount of work and and we're well
positioned to do a lot of great things
moving forward. Uh as we think as we
move to the next slide, one of the
things that I I want you all to know is
that the challenges that have faced AISD
regarding special education services is
not new. Uh we've had these challenges.
They've shown themselves in a variety of
ways for several years now, really going
back to 2018, 2019, and and and others
would argue well before that. And so, as
we talk specifically around the
engagement with TEA, I do want to point
out that there have been multiple
notifications, updates, you know,
investigations, uh, over the last
several years. And, uh, all of that
work, however, hasn't quite gotten us to
where we need to be. And so as we embark
on this next engagement with TEA, uh
it's certainly important to note that a
lot of things have occurred. And for the
state and for us as well, this is not
coming out of nowhere. I know for a lot
of our community members, a lot of our
stakeholders, uh it felt like it was was
new and maybe out of nowhere, but but
certainly it's something we've been
working on for quite some time.
So, as we transition to the next slide,
I do want to point out uh that, you
know, because of the renewed focus that
we have at AISD regarding special
education services, we've done a a
tremendous amount of things in a very
short period of time. I do want to
acknowledge uh some previous actions.
Just going back to May of 2022, uh one
of the things that we did was
commissioned a an audit, an assessment
by Dr. Stson, a I would say
worldrenowned, but I definitely
internationally known um special
education expert and she was able to
identify uh recommendations that would
really help improve the system and from
that point we made some structural
changes including adjustments to
leadership to ensure that the work
really aligned with the structure within
AISD. I would argue prior to that there
were bottlenecks there were challenges
that we had which is keeping information
and and the systems flowing the way they
needed to. One of the things that I
think is most impactful to the work was
was actually the the new the election of
the new board. We had new board members
come on in November uh elected in
November and then came on late December
and into January. And at that point, not
that there wasn't previously, but there
was a a kind of a refocusing uh
regarding special education services and
a clear alignment between the
administration uh and the board as to
what needed to happen. And so in
December of 2022, uh the board um if we
go to the next slide, um the board did
move forward with um identifying me uh
for the interim role. And I think one of
the things that's that's worth noting
here is is as y'all know, I've worked
with just about every one of y'all. Uh I
am a non-traditional. Um my my expertise
is in systems. Uh it's in um identifying
strategies to address the most
complicated issues an entity may face.
That's just the world that I've lived in
my entire career and and this is no
different. So we have unique opportunity
here. And so as I said once I came on
board it was clear what the focus was of
the organization. Again we have others
right we have other focus areas whether
it's multilingual education uh climate
and culture uh budget priorities but but
you know I keep on telling our team like
special education services is truly one
a above all else. uh the board uh
established an ad hoc committee which I
think is important to note when you
think about getting alignment between
the board and the administration. It's
important to have that touch point. You
know right now we have the information
sessions and we have the the board
meetings but really to to be aligned we
need to have like constant communication
and we need to make sure that uh they're
understanding the recommendations
because we are moving very uh forward
very aggressively. also want to point
out uh that in a very short period of
time we've been able to develop a
comprehensive strategy around special
education services acknowledging that
it's not just uh the students that
receive these services it's the entire
academic system that really needs to be
improved and we can talk about that in
detail maybe in the Q&A portion of the
the conversation uh and also
acknowledging that this is something
that we all share as as a system as AISD
you know finance operations procurement
no one is good uh unless special
education services are good uh and we're
doing what we need to be doing for our
students. And I think creating that
expectation for our system is important
uh and and we've done a lot in a very
short period of time including
developing a dashboard uh which allows
our um school communities, our
principles and executive directors to
understand where each of our students
are within a process. Uh and and you can
think about planning purposes, right? We
we have evaluations, we have ARS, we
have all these things that we have to
do, but understanding where each student
is in that process is incredibly
important and up until very recently, we
didn't have the tools to do that. Uh so
very um excited about the work we've
done, but there is a long way to go. So
as we transition to the next slide, I do
want to point out uh some things that
are um within the TEA current
recommendation and and kind of what that
means. Uh as you all know um several
weeks back we received a letter from TEA
stating that uh conservators uh were
being recommended for placement within
the special education department. I want
to be very clear that's not over the
board. It's not over the superintendent.
It's not over governance or procurement
or finance. It's specifically over
special education department. Uh this is
this is important because I believe our
community um responded noting kind of
what's occurring right now in Houston
and terrifying ter it is terrifying and
I and so the board aligned with the
administration you know was putting out
communication around what this is and
what it isn't. Uh I will tell you um in
our response to tea regarding the
initial findings we were proposing a
monitor which is different. Uh, a
monitor is someone that kind of looks
over your shoulders, is is a
collaborator with you, but ultimately
doesn't have a binding um
decision-making authority. Uh, a
conservator does. And so, right now, we
are in the process of working through
this pro this with TEA. Um, I suspect uh
ultimately wherever we land um it will
occur sometime in midsummer. Uh, the
board and and administration have been
aligned at every step along the way. Uh
so I think it's important uh to note
that we are very much aligned. We
communicate constantly and we're also
communicating to our larger uh community
uh in a more frequent basis and we're
transparent in and in a transparent way.
Something that I don't know has been
done in that way for quite some time. So
just important to continue to reinforce
that. Uh on the next slide I I think
it's important to talk about some of the
challenges we've had and some of the
progress we've made. Uh I I do want to
take a moment here and and describe one
of the like kind of foundational
challenges that we have and one of them
is that you know we use LSSPs and
diagnosticians
uh to do the evaluations for our
students receiving or maybe our students
that have been identified as potentially
receiving special education services. We
have 75 positions in Austin ISD. Right
currently right now we have 24 filled.
Uh and so as you can imagine with the
number of students that we have the the
pandemic and the slowdown in in in
evaluations coupled with the fact that
uh we're seeing an increase um and in
students being moved into this process
and there's conversations around that
we're we're not able to keep up with
with the load. Uh one thing I also want
to point out is in central Texas uh
there's only 256 licensed LSPs uh and
diagnosticians. So we have to
essentially take on and and compete for
a substantial portion of the available
LSPs and diagnosticians which means we
have to be incredibly aggressive. Uh
another thing I want to point out is uh
we have been moving very aggressively uh
through our evaluations. You can see
here some of the numbers. Uh we've done
4,000 since May of 2022 and over 8,000
uh since last year. So we have been
developing the system and moving the
system to be able to move through this.
Uh but we still have a good amount of
work to do. I do tell the trustees that
uh in all honesty this is not a
six-month challenge. This is not a year
challenge. This is an 18 to 24month
uh you know initiative that we have to
to go through to be where we want to be.
But we're well positioned to do it. on
the next slide just so that you all have
a sense of of what we're talking about
here when we build up and those of you
that know me like many of y'all probably
seen these types of things from me uh I
I am intentional about making sure
everybody in the organization
understands you know what task is at
hand what resources being allocated what
their role is in supporting that work
and so this is one of nine sheets that
just communicates the overall education
special education initiative that'll
occur over the next two years we're
wanting to be um incredibly will be
transparent. So, you're seeing us post
this uh and collaborate with our um our
uh stakeholders to improve it and and it
will evolve over time. But again, my
goal is to be able to communicate to
anybody and prove to anybody that we can
tackle this work and I don't think
there's another way that you can do it
unless you go through this type of
analysis. So, just wanted to provide uh
that for you. Is there like a highlight
on the recovery plan because that's I
have no I have I have a I have a
highlight and and I I will send that. I
didn't. Yeah, there's no way. I He is an
engineer by train. You need You need I
have it like on my I have it I have huge
sheets on my board. You know something
really quick about this. So say no and I
we both have the same. We love this.
Okay. And this is obviously just for
illustrative purposes. We don't expect
you to be able to read it, but this did
not exist in this district four months
ago. And so as trustees, no schedule for
recovery time. There was no project
management. Okay. Commissioner Shay, I
it floored me. I'm so sorry. Go ahead.
You take it away. I'm just so passionate
about Gant charts. Um,
no. And
Commissioner, I need all the prayer I
can get. He says that to a lot of
people.
So, I'm now on Commissioner uh
Travillian's prayer list. I I will take
it. I'm on there, too. I'm sure.
But I digress. Um,
whether they know it or not. Um, no, but
I digress. Uh, in all seriousness, you
know, um, one of the things that's
really exciting, um, uh, as we're
working with interim, uh, superintendent
Sigura is the project management lens,
the operational lens, like really
looking at how each of our divisions
within the district, each of the
campuses, right? looking at the
interconnections and the dependencies
and being realistic but ambitious about
how to solve persistent or complex
problems. And special education, it fits
in that exact category. And so, um, the
Gant chart that you see here, you know,
is going to be familiar to anybody who
works with project management. And
that's exactly what this system needs.
we need a functional, purposeful way of
getting the work done um at a systemic
level. So, I mean, I I just can't tell
you how much I have really just
appreciated and quite frankly really
love the way that this current
administration is tackling um the
persistent issues that we've had. That's
great. If if I could just digress for
one second, uh you know, this has been a
difficult problem since integration
because since integration, special ed
has been used to remove our discipline
problems and not to diagnose legitimate
issues that can be addressed. And what
I'm going to be interested in is as you
have broken out all of the things that
need to be done and some of the costs
that are associated with it, uh whether
TEA will align itself and allow you to
make changes that I don't see or have
not seen in any number of school
districts because the NAACP when I was
president sued the school district four
times uh because a lot of the kids who
failed the TAS exam were routed to
special ed because special ed kids did
not have to take the TAS exam. So, um,
if we can truly get to a point where
special ed becomes diagnostic and
whether and whether we can run a system
that actually helps kids will have a lot
to do with whether TEA will receive,
understand, and allow uh this le this
level of analysis.
I appreciate that. Uh, Commissioner, I I
will tell you that um we are approaching
this in a collaborative manner with TEA.
Um I think the approach that we're
taking is wellreceived by them. I think
in the past for right wrong or
indifferent AIC would commit to
milestones but not necessarily get there
as time passed and I think a lot of that
was just proving up you know how we
actually do it. Uh and so I I feel good
but you're absolutely right. You know
I'm telling our teams you know let's
disagregate the data. Let's figure out
you know do our students actually need
these services or do they need tier two
instruction? Right. Do we need tier
three instruction? and are we are we
providing professional development for
our teachers to ensure that students
don't move into a process that doesn't
serve them. And so all of that is that's
where the academic aspect of it comes
together. Uh and and we are pushing
quite aggressively. As you move on to
the next slide, uh just a couple points
of where we're going. Um you know, we're
going to continue to provide updates. Uh
in in recruitment is absolutely critical
for us. Uh we're working with the board
right now to develop an aggressive
compensation package. You will see in it
once delivered that it is hyperfocused
on attracting the resources we need to
complete this work. If you can imagine
you know attracting you know what 35% of
the actual available um you know group
of people you have to be competitive
right and so uh we're moving through it.
Um I will tell you that we're making
adjustments and refining. We are
continuing to provide updates. Uh, and
as we work with TEA over the next couple
weeks, we'll have updates not only to um
our community, but also to all of our
stakeholders, including y'all. Um, so I
I will pause there. Um, I know we need
to transition to another presentation,
but want to make sure there was space
for any questions that you all may have
regarding special education services.
Does the um is there essentially the
effect of a death penalty for the
district if you can't get out from under
this penalty order or whatever it's
called? Do they then take over
everything if you can't meet some metric
by some date? So one of the things uh so
yes, but many many many many things have
to have to occur um for us. It's just I
I think it's important for the community
to know what's at stake. Yeah, it's I
did not understand, for instance, with
Houston that if one school uh failed per
a certain number of years that the TEA
could come in and take over the entire
school district. I don't think most
people understand that. So, I don't know
what this means that you're now under
conservatorship for this program and I I
don't know what the potential
consequence is if you're not able to
turn it around by whatever their
requirements are. So I will start maybe
president singing if you'd like to chime
in. Uh I would say first and foremost
you know we need to identify what the
separation parameters um are with TEA
right so and and that's where that means
so what is our goal right right now we
we like TEA says we need to correct a
problem we agree we're in agreement we
need to correct this problem but what
does that mean? Does that mean 100% of
evaluations in a system of this size?
Well that's not necessarily realistic.
So we are commissioning an audit. Um
it's actually a collaboration with TEA.
Out of that audit will come the
recommendation for the goal that we have
to meet over a certain period of time. I
will tell you that the the time frame is
generally about two years. Uh and every
nine weeks the commissioner reviews kind
of the progress that we've made and
makes adjustments at that point. Uh and
so you know over that period of time we
will get to a place where we're we'll be
out of it. But you're right, you know,
we need to be able to communicate to our
stakeholders and our communities that if
we do not do this and we are not
committed, there could be at some point
in the distant future that possibility.
I don't know, President Singh, if you'd
like to.
Yes, to all of that and we are taking it
extremely seriously. The conservatorship
is just one step below a takeover and a
conservator can, as um Mr. Sigoda
mentioned, they can override any
decisions we make as a board. They won't
replace the board, but they can
basically make decisions on any program
area that impacts special education,
which could be anything from facilities
to HR,
our budget. It's a line item based on
detail. Yeah, it is it is it is we are
taking it extremely seriously and um
we're we're kind of running out of time,
but I do want to address the issue that
you just brought up is very relevant to
the next topic which is Mendes. Um and
thank you Councilwoman Fuentes for being
here because that lies in your district,
but it's a school that belongs to all of
us. And if you don't mind, let's switch
over to that topic because that one's
just as urgent.
All right. Um, so wanted to provide a
brief update regarding Mendes Middle
School. Uh, if we could go to the next
slide. I just want to provide a a brief
history of Mendes Middle School and some
of the challenges that the school
community has faced over the last
several years. So going back to 2013,
you can see the enrollment of 886 and
the MET standard. So, you know, the
state of Texas through TEA has different
standards that they review and update
every so often. We're actually going
through revision right now. Uh so the
met standard rating was an acceptable
rating at that time. So we go back to
2013 because that was the last time that
we feel as though Mendes was a stable
school community with a a rating that we
all you know can can acknowledge and
appreciate. So from 2014 to 2016 you can
see we saw a reduction in enrollment. uh
we um through the uh testing um at that
time the state testing you can see that
the improvement required was placed at
Mendes three consecutive years actually
five consecutive years through 2018 the
enrollment continued to decline until
2018 we were at 646 students I know many
of you all have seen Mendes many of
y'all probably even been in Mendes it's
quite a large campus um middle school
wise and so you can imagine what a
reduction in enrollment would feel like
at that campus uh in 2018 18, uh, the
state of Texas and AISD engaged in a
partnership. Uh, this was in an effort
to, um, kind of kind of pull Mendes back
to a stable place accountability wise.
Uh, it was it was mandated. Correct.
Well, yes, it was mandated. Uh, for lack
of a better term, it was mandated. Uh,
in 2019, the accountability rating was
then uh, F at 606. And as you move to
the next couple slides, I'm not sure
who's controlling slides. Sorry about
that. it got worse under the charter
school that you were required to bring
in by TVA. So generally so I I would say
that that partnership was not the the
actual formal required partnership. I
think AIST at the time engaged with a
partner kind of identifying this was a
likelihood. So it wasn't I would say
mandated by TA which is why you saw me
pause there. It was kind of a foregone
conclusion that we would get there. So
we at that time kind of initiated it. So
it wasn't TEA saying this it was hey we
need to go get a partner and help us out
is essentially what happened. Now here
is moving to the next slide you will see
in 2020 not rated state go back we could
go back real fast. Okay. Uh 6 uh 616
enrollment 2021 573. If you recall, this
is due to COVID the pandemic. Um the
state of Texas commissioner TEA um did
um al identified not rated campuses as
campuses that would would have likely
received a DRF. Uh so one of the things
that's important to note is through this
time we did have that partner in place.
uh in December of 2021, so about a year
and a half, well two and a half years
ago, uh the board voted to terminate its
partnership with the STEM coalition. So
at that point, we had a partner, right,
that um where they had the control over
the the the staff, the principal, the
way that they um instructed, all of that
was theirs. AIC had very little
influence, if any, uh into kind of the
culture and climate of that campus. Um
at that time AISD I think acknowledged
that the partnership was not moving in
the direction that we'd had hoped and
the agreement with that uh coalition was
terminated and so uh shortly thereafter
in March of 2022 which is just a year
ago AIC then entered a new partnership
uh with third futures and I think what's
important to note here that's not
included on the slide is because we
engaged with a new partner we actually
received an additional year. So um
you'll see here in the next slide, we're
not quite ready to move you there yet,
but in the next slide you'll see that
that next year does have an impact on
where we are today. So the partnership
was executed in 2022. Uh their
leadership came on um we at that point
also uh um made the decision to move
sixth grade out of Mendes. I'm not sure
how many of y'all are aware of this, but
um at the end of last year, the decision
was made by the administration to pull
out sixth grade from both Mendes and
Martin, and those students remained at
the elementary schools uh where they
attended fifth grade. Now, there's some
nuance to that, but generally speaking,
they stayed at the at their home
campuses. So, fast forward um to to 2022
2023, which is this year, our
partnership with Third Futures is in
place. uh they are um working with the
students and they are um moving towards
uh an accountability rating of C or
better. That's the goal, right? And that
would effectively break the chain
because on the next slide, if you could
move to next slide, you can see as
President Singh mentioned that there are
steps along the way yearbyear that if
Mendes Middle School does not meet
accountability or improve or action
isn't taken by the board, a um a school
of managers could be placed or a
conservator could be placed or the
school could be identified for closure.
All of these things are are up for
consideration if we don't get Mendes
back on track. Uh and so this is a very
good slide. I think it helps communicate
kind of, you know, the accountability,
the break and the chain and then what
occurs at each step based on, you know,
where we are and who has what authority
to do what. I would say as right as of
right now, AISD has limited opportunity
to engage with the school community. Uh,
so I would say that with Third Futures
because we have a contract. We don't
have the ability to to um I would say
dictate the way that instruction occurs
at Mendes. We allow them the space um
because that's part of the agreement and
the agreement had to be reviewed and
approved by TEA to do what they think is
best. Uh and so they provide updates to
the board. There was one that was
provided just last month. There'll be
one again in June. And so for us, we're
always taking information and trying to
determine, you know, what the best steps
are for Mendes Middle School because
those are our students. Um, as we move
forward to the next slide, just briefly,
can I just clarify? So, if they are
successful at the end of this year in
getting a C average or better, that
breaks the chain. That breaks the chain
of the state being able to come in and
take over. Correct. And is that a
year-toyear thing? It doesn't reset the
clock for another like three years in a
row or something like that. It does not.
It It truly breaks the chain. So if
Mendes were to make a C, it would break
the chain. If they make a D, then this
year effectively becomes a baseline
year. Then they have one additional year
to make a C. So effectively we've got
two years uh to hit that mark. Um we are
doing everything to support you know
them in that effort. What they want is
what we want, which is to get Mendes to
a stable position. Um, so as far as
third uh third future partnership, I I
do want to make sure it's communicated
here that we are collaborating with them
uh and and because they are our
students. We acknowledge that. We want
to make sure our school community
understands that we're here for them. Uh
so we are working with them uh quite
closely. Um and and that'll continue. So
as we move forward, I think there's a
couple things that I'd like to point
out. The first is that it's important
that we develop a communications I mean
an engagement strategy around the
education plan. This is in the next
slide for Martin Mendes uh and the sixth
grade students. So when I think about
this area, I think about the needs of
all of our students and we need to make
some significant changes if we're going
to stabilize these school communities.
Uh you think about, you know, Mendes
right now with the partnership that we
have. Martin has has had declining
enrollment. Ne both of them do not have
sixth grade. And so all of these
decisions were made in the not too
distant past. We need to evaluate and
determine as a community what's the best
path forward for our students. And so we
are looking at developing a community
coalition to determine like what the
long-term vision is for our students in
these communities. Uh and then that will
help inform the steps the board takes
along with the administration, you know,
for each of these schools. So there's a
lot happening. Um, but wanted to make
sure that that y'all are aware that
we'll be looking to y'all as we partner.
Trusty Sabata and uh, Council Member um,
Fuentes have been incredible and there's
a lot more work to be done, but uh, it's
going to require all of us working
together to to get this where it needs
to be. You um, and I I'm just going to
ask one question. I know if we could
have a follow-up meeting, that'd be
great. Um, with the trusty step and our
at large trustees, that would be super
helpful. Um, thank you for this
information. Is there what additional
resources might be helpful to AISD at
this point given the the severe nature
that we're in with Mendes Middle School?
What would be most helpful at this time
from the city and from the county?
So, um I think at this point it would be
participation in a like a a a um an
agreement to participate to to solve
this for these school communities. Uh
and in my mind, that may be a
resolution. Um you know, because we'll
have to spend resources, right? We're
going to have to engage with our
communities. That's going to require
time. It's going to require partners. Uh
we're going to have to figure out how to
get to our communities. many of our
families are working multiple jobs. You
know, they're not able to get to the
schools, but we need to get to them. Uh
and and we have resources, but y'all
have networks that we often can't engage
with. So, or get to, I should say. So,
um you know, on the resource side, I
think that's part of the planning that's
going to come out of this. I think at
this point, not unlike some of the
things that y'all put on that on that
table behind me or on that wall, it's it
needs to be like a clear like alignment
between the city of Austin and AISD to
co-plan to figure this out for this part
of town. Like that to me would be really
impactful. Um, and so I we can talk
about what that might look like in a
future meeting. As far as funds go and
things like that, I think at this point
we're pretty well positioned, but we
need thought partners and we need
commitments to do the work.
Um, madame chair, I think that um it
it's going to be important for us to uh
to build community networks. The place
where I've seen it done the best uh was
initially through the Austin project and
the work and planning that it did in the
St. John project. It basically
identified a whole lot of the resources
and started creating meetings. Allan
Weekes and his team uh was a part of
that. Um I I think that it is important
to take the blueprint, the Austin
Project AV blueprint. Now, you might add
other things to it that are
communitydriven, but they did a good job
of identifying things that could be done
and and we use that type of process with
the community resiliency trust as we
developed an outreach plan during the
pandemic. But I think that on paper and
with documentation,
uh, the St. John Project really lays
out, uh, how to work with comm community
with community and and, um, and I would
encourage that and and, um, we're
certainly willing to be helpful because
a lot of the places that need the most
attention are in the eastern crescent
and we want to be a part of the
solution. I appreciate that and I think
you're right. I think it is a a
regionable a regional approach to the
work. I I do speak to to Allan quite a
bit. Um certainly appreciate the
community and schools model. I think
it's important to understand the whole
needs of our community. Um so I'm right
there with you and I think that's what's
going to take I think it's something
like that that type of effort is what's
going to be required to figure to to do
this correctly and and the county is a
funer of the Austin Voices and Education
initiative uh that Allen's undertaking
at web. Um, so I think this needs to be
a running item on our our committee
agenda and because if TEA comes in and
and so if I'm understanding they would
take over the special ed operations if
there's a continued failure or could
they take over the entire school
district?
So there's two thing two different
special ed and then there's the Mendes.
Yeah, with Mendes, if we continue to um
get an F in that school, they can take
over the whole district. I think we do
have an option also to to close down the
school and reopen it as something else.
But if if we assume it stays open,
that's that's how you get to a takeover.
With special education, there's not
necessarily a clear path to a takeover
because we haven't done the audit yet
and they haven't told us yet what we're
going to be accountable for. But we
ourselves are holding ourselves
accountable to certain things. But we
don't know yet what what TEA is gonna um
bring to us. I I think there's um a
legitimate fear on the part of the
community if TEA were to come in and
take over. There's not alignment at all
on on values and on goals and on um even
respecting the community. So, um, I
think this needs to be on our agenda
and, um, uh, I think there's value in us
brainstorming how else we can, um, be of
support. Thank you. So, I want to do a
quick time check. We're already at 1:31,
so I have not done a great job with time
management in this meeting, but I wanted
to Are you guys okay if we have five
more minutes just for the whole meeting?
I think we can wrap up the other stuff,
but I wanted to give Tristata a moment
to share since Mendes is in her
district. Sure. Um, as you were talking
about partners, uh, you know, AISD has
been sorry, AISD has been in a situation
like this before when we were working in
East Austin schools where the issue is
again uh, and it's all that organizing
work with um, with Central Texas
Interfaith and the Alliance Schools. So
we have history of success from Zavala
being uh the number 64 64 schools that
became a blue ribbon school. So and it's
all about really bringing in the
community. So I know that's another
resource uh and and they're still very
strong and active in East Austin. So I
just wanted to to put that out there
that uh we can be successful uh with the
community. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you, Mr. Sigura. Yeah. Thank you. Uh, oh
yes, trusty Alter, just really quickly,
um, thank you for bringing this up. I
think this is an example of the help
section of of what we're trying to um,
think about in terms of how we're how
we're how we're doing things and and I
appreciate you raising raising the
issues and appreciate Council Member
Fuentes coming. Um, I think this is a
great example of where we all need to to
work together to to help us achieve what
our community needs um to thrive. So,
thank you. Really appreciate that
sentiment. Thank you all. So, if you
don't mind, I'm going to um Thank you,
Mr. Seagura. He's doing an amazing job.
By the way, I just have to I have to
brag. We one of the main complaints TEA
had and we had ourselves about ourselves
was the backlog of evaluations. But in
this school year, we've already
completed 45% more evaluations than we
did the entire previous school year. And
we still have like five weeks left in
this school year. And this is with like
probably fewer staff. So that that big
Gant chart, that Gant chart you saw, it
created efficiencies without sacrificing
quality. And that's something to be
proud of. So thank you.
Yes, that's right. It's it's a great
mix. Um, okay. So, I'm gonna move on
very quickly. So, we have a written
report on resilience hubs, and I
apologize that we're not going to be
able to devote much time to it, but I
did want to give an opportunity if
anybody had any questions. Um, the
report is in your packet. Are there any
questions or comments that anybody had
or if there's anyone from the staff that
wanted to highlight?
I'd just like to make a request if we
can. Um, oh, is Laura Patina going to
speak? Okay, great. I'll hold my
question then. Go ahead, Laura.
Hi, joint subcommittee members. Um, I
just wanted to highlight that um we've
been integrating all resilience hubs
effort into current emergency operation
uh emergency operations. Uh the report
that you see in front of you really has
an uh two major significant updates. one
is a proposed spending plan and I'm
happy to answer any questions about that
that really summarize how we're going to
move forward with community outreach uh
a community stipen fund and really
looking at uh the programming side of
resilience hubs related to health and
related to other planning and engagement
activities for the future. Um the other
key highlight is how that's being
incorporated into emergency operations
and you will see um in in the proposed
fund which is on on page three of the
document um that it talks about
infrastructure and so that is where
we're looking at u looking to complement
uh redundant power systems and then
implementation of those. Um the last
final comment and I know I have to keep
it uh super short and sweet is just to
um remind uh the committee that
resilience hubs are one is one tool in
the toolbox that we have for an entire
resilience program. And so in the coming
weeks we will be releasing the first
iteration of our comprehensive
resilience framework that we've
developing um for for the past year. And
so that will help bring other elements
of resilience into the discussion beyond
resilience hubs that were touched on um
earlier in this meeting today.
Thank you.
Any questions for Laura?
Uh I think as it um
develops further, it would be it'd be
useful to have a little bit more time on
it. We had um set aside a million um
600,000 at the county for uh resilience
efforts. We've gotten a very rough draft
proposed spending plan and I don't know
how it um coordinates with this
resilient plan resilience hubs plan and
I don't know if that's part of the
conversation that's happening among the
city and the county uh in the school
district. So that would be useful for me
to have a better understanding of. And
um and yes, the what resilience hubs are
not is a useful um description as well
because I think a lot of people do think
of them as being shelters,
maybe not overnight sleeping shelters,
but day shelters. Um so I think um a
little more time in a future meeting
would be would be valuable also to give
us a sense of where we are as a
threeparty entity working on this. I
appreciate that. And just as uh one
point uh after after uh Storm Yuri uh we
put together an afteraction report that
laid out all that we did uh and
recommendations that we have been
putting in place since then. I think
it's quite instructive and it works
through our emergency management team.
So, I would encourage you to get a copy
of that and see how we can align. Thank
you. All right. Thank you, Laura. Really
appreciate that update. Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. So, um next we are going to just
the standing items. Uh the next
basically we have unfinished business,
new business, proposed future agenda
items. Um, I think I've heard about
Mendes and SPED being included on the
next agenda. We can do a longer
discussion on the resilience hubs and
maybe next steps and some of this. I
think the next meeting is going to be at
the commissioner's court. So, we'll just
coordinate and and think about what we
might want to have on that agenda. Is
does anybody have a comment? Uh, just a
note for folks because I I I don't I
don't know that this is being
coordinated with the school district,
but it seems Mike, please. It seems to
me it should be um the um integral care
and county staff came forward on Tuesday
with a request for us to fund $270,000
in youth and child um uh mental health
crisis suicide prevention programs. Um
it seems to me that that's a really
important thing to be coordinating with
the school district on and we did vote
to fund that yesterday in our ARPA
allocation. So, it's a new initiative.
Um, it seems like it's a a true hair on
fire problem. There just extremely
alarming statistics about the rates of
it. And, um, if you're not aware that
it's underway, integral care is heading
it up. Per, I don't know if you have any
more information to add about who our
key staff at the county are that are
working on it or maybe the city does,
but we voted $270,000 in funding on it
yesterday. Oh, wonderful. Right. the the
city of Boston Austin public health is
partnering with integral care and the
county and between the three of us
there'll be an an awareness campaign and
there's also um $170,000 that the county
allocated towards expanding training on
mental health for aid uh regarding
youth. So that definitely is something
that we'd like to partner with AISD on.
Thank you. Appreciate that. Okay. So,
we'll follow up with you all on that.
So, who who specifically is the person
that presented that item, the budget
item to commissioners? Um, the integral
care folks and then Laura Pito. Laura
Pudau at the county. Okay. Okay. Well,
that brings up a point. um if if budget
is something we could talk about because
there we are connected through programs
uh that we talked about earlier and is
that something that we we can talk about
since we're all in that process right
now? Yes. Yes. Thank you. Thank you. All
right. Yes. on budget um for the parent
sport specialists um for a variety of
reasons and I can go into this with
anyone who wants to go into detail um
the level of funding is not where it was
precoid um the grant request that came
in from AISD was lower than precoid um
we have put in a request that we would
like it to go back up to pre-COVID
levels from the city um but there are a
lot of misconceptions about the origin
of that program and as I understand that
program originated with the city, you
know, funding it. What program is it
again? Parent support specialists. Um,
but so for my colleagues, um, in
particular, I will just flag that, you
know, we have some work to do on seeing
if we can increase that funding. And if
that is a need that AISD has in the
budget process, we need to be having
those conversations early and often. Um,
because the we have to make sure balls
are not dropped again. Y on that so that
we can provide the supports to to the
community. Um but I would benefit from
help from other folks in in keeping that
moving forward. Do we need to talk about
that before our next JSC in August?
Yes. Yes. Okay. All right. Thank you.
Anyone else?
All right. So, um and then next we don't
have a date yet for the August meeting.
Correct. Okay. No, we're polling uh
members for August the 11th or August
the 18th. Okay. And I think maybe you've
gotten an email about that. So, we have
budget. I know Stephanieth. Oh, the
25th. Okay. Sorry. The 25th. 11th and
Yeah. Okay. Wonderful. I think you all
are in the middle of budget on the
August 11th. So, 25th is budget time for
us as well. 18th is budget for us.
All right. Well, I think that's we got
through the agenda. So is there a motion
to adjurnn?
All right. Okay. So we have a motion by
commissioner Sheay, second by trustee
Sapata, and barring any objection, this
meeting is adjourned. Thank you. It is
142.
Thank you. Good.